[Music]
why is dream specs way better than real
sex
look let's play come when you want them
to girl that is so true when I'm done
they're done hello
ever think about all the stuff we've
done and wonder how we did not die it's
a cultural thing we are too bad as
planes like those [__] who raised
Wonder Woman we've worked our asses off
we've opened up our own store we'll
women when four hundred and ninety-three
thousand dollars in debt I'm Clara Luna
I am going to invest 1.7 million dollars
on you we would love but in my
experience business and friendship don't
always mix you don't have to worry your
pretty little head my head is not little
it's just that my breasts are humongous
you want to be a businesswoman you're
gonna have to act like a boss you have
to fire him
what don't hate me hate Mel was her idea
witness my tragic moment introducing a
new product at her launch party she just
wants to steal our ideas we don't break
this bitch's back
yeah I'll get Claire gonna punch that
[__] in the face I would marry you if I
was in the coochie those two peppers
they are very spicy just a little sliver
goes a long way your peppers are really
hot goat's milk soda coke the throat
you